Všichni potřebujeme schopnost komunikovat soukromé informace bez strachu, že nás někdo odposlouchává. Ale navrhnout
spolehlivý systém pro to není snadné. V dnešní epizodě Qiskit in the Classroom si povíme o tom, jak nám
s tím může pomoci kvantová distribuce klíčů.
Vítej zpět v Qiskit in the Classroom. V tomto seriálu se budeme věnovat tématům, se kterými se můžeš setkat na vysokoškolském kurzu
spojeném s kvantovým počítáním. Ke každému videu je přiložen interaktivní modul odkazovaný v popisu, takže
si ho určitě prohlédni. Dnes se vydáme do oblasti kvantové kryptografie. Kryptografie je studium
technik pro bezpečnou komunikaci. To je neuvěřitelně důležité pro mnoho oblastí našeho života. Pokaždé, když použiješ
heslo pro přihlášení na web, pošleš digitální platbu nebo když vlády přenáší vojenské informace, vše se děje
prostřednictvím nějakého kryptografického protokolu, aby odposlouchávač nemohl zjistit naše tajemství. Ale je tu napětí. Jak
zajistíme, že osoba, se kterou chceme komunikovat, naši zprávu pochopí, ale nikdo jiný ne?
Historicky kryptografové vymysleli mnoho různých protokolů, aby jejich zprávy byly co nejvíce imunní
vůči odposlouchávačům. Někdy se dvě strany, které chtějí bezpečně komunikovat, předem dohodnou na nějakém
kódu, který je doufejme tak komplikovaný, že ho odposlouchávač nedokáže prolomit. Ale jak
nám ukázali lidé jako Alan Turing a další váleční luštitelé kódů, i ty nejsložitější kódy lze
prolomit. Ideálně bychom chtěli posílat zprávy zašifrované tak, aby v nich absolutně nebyl žádný vzor
a žádný způsob, jak by je odposlouchávač mohl pochopit bez toho, aby měl tajný náhodný klíč, který znají jen odesílatel a
příjemce. Ale tím se vystavujeme nové zranitelnosti. Jak můžeme tento klíč odeslat a mít jistotu, že
ho nikdo nezachytí? V roce 1984 přišli Charles Bennett a Jill Brassard s
metodou bezpečného odeslání klíče pomocí kvantových bitů, která se nyní nazývá BB84. Klíčovou vlastností těchto kvantových
bitů neboli qubitů, která tento protokol umožňuje, je to, že se řídí principem neurčitosti. Nemůžeš
měřit kvantový systém, aniž bys ho narušil. Dnes začneme příkladem jednoduchého kryptografického kódu. Pak ti ukážu,
jak nám kvantová distribuce klíčů a princip neurčitosti umožňují používat téměř neprolomitelné
šifrování. Provedu tě protokolem BB84 podrobně a nakonec ho spustíme na skutečném kvantovém
počítači. Nejprve začněme hrou, kterou možná znáš, zvanou kryptogram.
Dostaneš sekvenci zdánlivě náhodných písmen, ale díky svým znalostem vzorců v anglickém
jazyce můžeš zaměnit jedno písmeno za jiné a zprávu rozluštit. Tady je příklad. Toto je
tajná zpráva s jednoduchou substituční šifrou. Takže všechna R představují jedno písmeno, M představují
jiné, a tak dále. Jestli si to chceš zkusit sám, video teď zastav.
Ukázalo se, že tato zpráva byla zašifrována velmi jednoduchou šifrou zvanou Caesarova šifra, kde je
abeceda posunuta o určitý počet, v tomto případě 9. Takže A se stane J, B
se stane K, C se stane L a tak dále. Čím delší zpráva, tím snazší je
vidět vzor. Takže u zprávy tak dlouhé, jakou máme, je Caesarova šifra nebo jakákoli jiná šifra, která jen
nahrazuje jedno písmeno abecedy jiným, poměrně snadno prolomitelná. Bezpečnějším způsobem kódování tajné
zprávy je tzv. jednorázový blok. S jednorázovým blokem můžeš mít pro každé písmeno ve
zprávě jiný posun. Stačí jen svému příteli říct, jaký byl posun u každého písmene, aby mohl zprávu dekódovat.
Tento seznam posunů se nazývá klíč nebo blok. Říká se mu jednorázový blok, protože se použije jednou a pak se zahodí.
Pokud se použije vícekrát, začnou se objevovat vzory, které by mohly šifrování učinit prolomitelným. S šifrováním
jednorázovým blokem jsou jak zašifrovaná zpráva, tak klíč každý zvlášť jen náhodným řetězcem nesmyslů. Ale
když je dáš dohromady, z šumu se vynoří tajná zpráva.
Udělejme krátký příklad. Řekněme, že jsem již vytvořila a poslala příteli tento jednorázový blok, který se obvykle zapisuje v
binárním kódu. A pak chci poslat zprávu „Miluji kvantum". Pak bych zprávu zakódovala
pomocí jednorázového bloku takto. Nejprve převedeme písmena ve zprávě na binární kód. Každé písmeno A až Z bude
odpovídat číslům 1 až 26 zapsaným v binárním kódu. Takže A bude 0 0
0 1, B 0 0 1
0, C 0 0 1 1 a tak
dále. A mezera bude jen samé nuly.
Toto je pak podoba zprávy. Zprávu zakódujeme provedením XOR mezi každým bitem ve zprávě a
odpovídajícím bitem v jednorázovém bloku. Pokud jsi XOR ještě neviděl/a,
jde o zkratku pro „exclusive or" – exkluzivní nebo. XOR dvou bitů bude jedničkou, jen pokud je
pouze jeden z bitů jedničkou, a nulou, pokud jsou oba nula nebo oba jedna. Takže první sada pěti bitů v zakódované
zprávě bude 1 0
0 1 1. Zbytek XOR nechám na tobě. Ale podstatné je,
že tato zpráva je nyní jen náhodný řetězec nul a jedniček bez vzoru. Je zcela nečitelná pro kohokoli, kdo
nemá jednorázový blok, který jsme použili k zašifrování zprávy. Co jsme se tedy doposud naučili? Některá šifrování
jsou lepší než jiná a některá může chytrý člověk hledající vzory v zašifrované
zprávě odhalit. Ale skutečně náhodný klíč, který posune každé písmeno v tajné zprávě o jiný náhodný počet, nelze
odhalit, protože ve zprávě nejsou žádné vzory. Jedinou zranitelností v takovém schématu je zajistit, aby klíč
použitý k zašifrování zprávy nepadl do nesprávných rukou. Právě zde přichází na řadu kvantová distribuce klíčů.
Použitím qubitů přišli Bennett a Brassard s metodou, jak se dvě strany dohodnou na klíči a
mohou být přiměřeně jisté, že třetí strana tajně neposlouchala. Tento protokol BB84 je trochu složitý, ale
projdeme ho krok za krokem. Pro toto vysvětlení si přivolejme zpět naše staré přátele Alici a
WEBVTT
Boba. Protokol začíná tím, že Alice připraví sadu qubitů k odeslání Bobovi. Tyto qubity obsahují
informace, které se stanou jejich sdíleným jednorázovým blokem neboli klíčem. Alice nejprve vygeneruje dvě náhodné sekvence
stejné délky. Jedna je náhodná sekvence nul a jedniček a druhá je náhodná sekvence X a Z, které představují
bázi, ve které připraví své qubity. Pak každý qubit připraví v kvantovém stavu podle
kombinace báze a bitové hodnoty zobrazené v této tabulce. Takže pokud je bit nula a báze je z, připraví
qubit ve stavu nula. Nebo pokud je bit jedna a báze je X, připraví ho ve stavu minus. Pokud
si nejsi jistý/á, co jsou tyto báze a kvantové stavy, to je v pořádku. Hlavní věc, kterou musíš vědět, je, že
měření v každé bázi mají vždy jen dva možné výsledky: 0 nebo 1 pro Z-bázi a plus nebo minus pro X-
bázi. Pokud změříš stav nula v Z-bázi, vždy dostaneš nulu.
Ale pokud změříš stejný stav v X-bázi, dostaneš náhodný výsledek – buď plus nebo minus, každý s 50%
pravděpodobností. Alice tedy může připravit řetězec qubitů takto, kde je zde náhodný řetězec
nul a jedniček a zde je náhodný řetězec X a Z. Takže první prvek každé z jejích
dvou sekvencí byl 0 a X. To znamená, že první qubit připraví ve stavu plus, a tak
dále. Jakmile připraví všechny stavy qubitů, Alice tyto qubity pošle Bobovi a Bob si náhodně vybere mezi X
a Z jako bázi, ve které každý z nich změří. Přidáme tedy k tabulce několik řádků
reprezentujících Bobovy volby a měření. Tady jsou Bobova
měření a volby báze. A tady jsou výsledky jeho měření qubitů, které mu Alice poslala. Nakonec Bob
může každé měření převést na bit pomocí stejné tabulky, kterou Alice použila k přípravě svých qubitů. Když změří
stav nula nebo plus, přiřadí bitovou hodnotu nula. A tam, kde změří stav jedna nebo minus, zapíše
jedničku. Bobův výsledný bitový řetězec je tedy tento poslední řádek.
Všimni si, že když se báze Aliciny přípravy a Bobova měření shodují, shodují se i jejich bity.
Ale pokud Alice zvolí přípravu v Z a Bob měří v X nebo naopak,
odpovídající bity Alici a Boba nutně nebudou stejné. Způsob, jak se oba dohodnou na bitovém řetězci
pro svůj jednorázový blok, je zavolat si a říct si, které báze použili pro každý qubit.
Kde se báze shodují, bit si ponechají, a kde se neshodují, bit zahodí.
V tomto případě se tedy Alice a Bob oba dohodnou na bitovém řetězci 0 0 1 0
0. Jak toto schéma chrání před neodhalenými odposlouchávači? Podívejme se, co se stane, když takový odposlouchávač
jménem Eva zachytí qubity, které Alice posílá Bobovi. Neví, v jakém stavu tyto qubity jsou ani jak
je Alice připravila. Takže díky principu neurčitosti a něčemu zvanému teorém o neklonování nemůže
jednoduše vytvořit identickou kopii qubitů, aby ji předala Bobovi. Pokud by mohla, pak by mohla
odposlouchávat bez odhalení. Místo toho uhádne bázi, ve které každý qubit změří, změří je a poté
připraví novou sadu falešných qubitů k odeslání Bobovi. Existují i jiné záludnější způsoby, jak by Eva mohla zkusit
zjistit informace o qubitech, ale žádný z nich princip neurčitosti neobejde.
Budeme tedy předpokládat tuto přímočarou metodu Evina odposlouchávání. Tady je tabulka popisující
Alicinu přípravu, Evino zachycení a Bobovo konečné měření. Takže nyní, když si
Alice a Bob zavolají a porovnají své báze, rozhodnou se ponechat si tyto bity pro svůj klíč, ale
bity se neshodují. Je to proto, že Bob měřil qubity, které připravila Eva, nikoli původní qubity, které měla Alice.
Pokud porovnají podmnožinu bitů ve svých bitových řetězcích, uvidí, že se některé neshodují, a
předpokládají, že musel být přítomen odposlouchávač. Protože tedy Eva byla odhalena, Alice a Bob zahodí
své bitové řetězce a začnou protokol od začátku. Ale pokud by Eva neposlouchala a podmnožina bitů,
kterou Alice a Bob porovnali, by se shodovala, pak by mohli jít dál a použít zbývající bity, které
neporovnávali, jako svůj sdílený klíč. Jakmile mají Alice a Bob sdílený klíč, Alice může Bobovi posílat zašifrované zprávy a
Bob je jako jediný může dešifrovat pomocí klíče. Teď, když jsme protokol prošli, pojďme ho vyzkoušet na
kvantovém počítači. Pro tento experiment je třeba mít na paměti pár věcí. Zaprvé,
BB84 je opravdu užitečný jen tehdy, když jsou Alice a Bob daleko od sebe. V experimentu, který hodláme provést, jsou Alice
a Bob na stejném kvantovém čipu. Takže tento experiment nebude užitečný pro výměnu soukromých informací, ale je to
stále dobrá konceptuální demonstrace BB84.
Zadruhé, skutečné kvantové počítače mají šum. Takže i když se Alicina přípravná báze shoduje s Bobovou měřicí bází
a žádný odposlouchávač nebyl přítomen, stále existuje malá šance, že změří různé bity kvůli chybám
v kvantovém počítači. Při porovnávání bitových řetězců kvůli kontrole odposlouchávačů musejí mít určitou toleranci k chybám, než
dojdou k závěru, že je musel trápit odposlouchávač a zahodí celý klíč. Nyní s těmito
výhradami začněme experimentem bez odposlouchávače. Nejprve náhodně
vygenerujeme tři různé bitové řetězce, každý s 20 bity. První je Alicin počáteční bitový
řetězec. Druhý je seznam bází, ve kterých Alice připraví své qubity.
Zde jsme zvolili nulu pro reprezentaci Z-báze a jedničku pro reprezentaci X-báze. Poslední seznam jsou báze,
ve kterých Bob změří každý qubit. Na základě těchto tří seznamů můžeme sestavit circuit diagram s instrukcemi pro
Alicinu přípravu a Bobova měření. Všechny qubity začínají ve stavu nula. Aby připravila qubity ve
Z-bázi, Alice buď nedělá nic pro stav nula, nebo aplikuje NOT neboli X gate, zobrazený jako modré rámečky označené X,
pro stav jedna. Pro přípravu v X-bázi aplikuje buď Hadamard gate, který převede nulu do stavu plus,
nebo NOT gate následovaný Hadamard gate pro přípravu stavu minus. Poté pošle qubity Bobovi. Další sada rámečků
v circuit reprezentuje Bobova měření. Pro měření v Z-bázi nemusí aplikovat žádné další gates.
WEBVTT
Jen změří, což je zobrazeno těmito šedými rámečky. Pro měření v X-bázi nejprve aplikuje Hadamard
a pak změří. Tento circuit spustíme pomocí Qiskit runtime primitive sampler. Výstupem je Bobův bitový
řetězec měření. Poté můžeme porovnat Bobův bitový řetězec s Aliciným počátečním bitovým řetězcem a zahodit bity,
kde se jejich báze neshodovaly. A vidíme, že oba dostanou stejný klíč.
Pamatuj, že jde o skutečný hardware, takže se občas může stát, že bit, který by se shodovat měl, se neshoduje. V tomto případě se všechny
bity shodují, ale pokud to znovu spustíš sám/sama, může se vyskytnout chyba – pokud je ale věrnost blízká jedné,
Alice a Bob mohou být přiměřeně jisté, že žádný odposlouchávač nebyl přítomen. Teď se podívejme, co se stane, když Eva zachytí
qubity. Nyní máme dva circuit. První ukazuje Alicinu přípravu a Evino zachycení a
měření. Druhý ukazuje Evinu přípravu falešných qubitů a Bobovo měření.
Tyto circuit můžeme spustit jako předtím a pak vidět, co by Alice a Bob dostali při porovnání svých bitových
řetězců. Tentokrát dostanou věrnost 6 opakující se. To je výrazně nižší, než
co by mohl vysvětlit šum kvantového počítače. Dojdou tedy k závěru, že Eva odposlouchávala. Kvantové počítání je
dobře známé a často přeceňované pro svůj potenciál řešit obtížné problémy. Ale kvantová komunikace a kryptografie
dostávají mnohem méně pozornosti, přestože potenciál, který kvantum může v těchto oblastech nabídnout, je stejně
velký a vzrušující. Dnes jsme probrali nejdříve objevený protokol pro kvantovou distribuci klíčů, který je
prakticky imunní vůči neodhalenému odposlouchávání. Jestli si chceš vyzkoušet posílání neprolomitelného kódu s
kvantově certifikovaným klíčem, přejdi na modul odkazovaný v popisu.
Díky za sledování a uvidíme se příště.